Youth sports families and fans huddle up. Wherever life takes you, Game Changer keeps you connected. Stream games live and full HD when you can't be there. Get play-by-play updates right on your phone and share game highlights with everyone. Full bragging rights included. Live the game like never before with Game Changer. Create your free account today at gc.com. Where we live, work, socialize can actually have an effect on our health and well-being.
青少年体育家庭和球迷们，聚拢过来。无论生活将你带向何方，Game Changer都能让你保持联系。在无法亲临现场时，观看高清直播。直接在手机上获取比赛实况更新，并与所有人分享精彩瞬间。包含完整的炫耀权利。使用Game Changer，以全新方式体验比赛。今天就访问gc.com创建您的免费账号。我们居住、工作、社交的地方实际上会对我们的健康和福祉产生影响。
And those effects can be deadly. If people are stressed because they're struggling to pay the bills or facing ongoing aggression in the form of discrimination, research shows people's health suffers. But how do we know this? How do we change it? In this episode, we talk with one psychologist who takes the psychological research from the lab into medical settings, helping patients and their doctors improve their care and their quality of life. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Elizabeth Brondolo is a professor of psychology at St. John's University in New York. She is also chair of the American Psychological Association's Working Group on Stress and Health Disparities. Her research on the health effects of racism and ethnic discrimination has led to efforts to improve the quality of care
而这些影响可能是致命的。研究表明，如果人们因为难以支付账单而感到压力，或者面临来自歧视的持续攻击，人们的健康就会受损。但我们怎么知道这一点呢？我们如何改变它？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，她将实验室的心理学研究带入医疗环境，帮助患者及其医生改善治疗和生活质量。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学话语》。伊丽莎白·布隆多洛是纽约圣约翰大学的心理学教授。她还是美国心理学协会压力与健康差距工作组的主席。她对种族主义和族裔歧视对健康影响的研究，促使人们努力改善护理质量
to ethnically and economically diverse communities in and around the New York area. Welcome, Dr. Brandolo. Thank you. Thank you very much for having me. For most of your career, you've researched the health effects of stress, specifically. heart disease and particularly in minorities in lower income populations. What differences did you find in how these populations experience stress? There's several differences. First, low income and many racial and ethnic minority individuals face more stress and they face more stress that they can report. They have more experiences of, for example, more severely severe, daily hassles. They have more negative
针对纽约地区及周边的多元族裔和经济多样化社区。欢迎您，布隆多洛博士。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。在你的大部分职业生涯中，你专门研究压力的健康影响，特别是心脏病，尤其是在少数族裔和低收入群体中。你在这些群体如何经历压力方面发现了什么不同？有几个不同之处。首先，低收入以及许多种族和少数族裔个人面临更多的压力，并且他们面临的压力是他们可以报告的。例如，他们有更多的严重日常琐事的经历。他们有更多的负面
life events, things like divorce or problems in housing, then people who are at higher levels of socioeconomic stress. And for many low-income people and certain racial and ethnic minorities, they're also exposed to more trauma, including trauma that results from violent assault across their lifespan. But they also have other kinds of stressors. So, for example, people who have low SES are more likely to get divorced, people who live in very serious. People who live in very structurally disadvantaged communities may experience more child maltreatment. They're exposed to more indoor pollution in their homes, things like lead and vermin and certain poor quality housing. And in some cases, but not in every part of the country,
生活事件，比如离婚或住房问题，比处于较高社会经济压力水平的人更多。对于许多低收入人群以及某些种族和少数族裔来说，他们也暴露于更多的创伤中，包括一生中遭受暴力袭击导致的创伤。但他们也有其他种类的压力源。例如，社会经济地位（SES）低的人更有可能离婚，生活在非常严重的人。生活在结构性失劣社区的人可能会经历更多的虐待儿童。他们在家中接触到更多的室内污染，如铅、害虫和某些劣质住房。在某些情况下，但并非在国家的每个地方，
they're exposed to more outdoor pollution and more crime and violence. So they're exposed overall to more stressors. Those stressors themselves change because they create a context that people live in, and they change the way people think and feel about themselves, about other people, and the world at large. So discrimination is a stressor that's faced by many groups, and racial or ethnic discrimination changes the way people think and feel about themselves, but most importantly, about other people. So when people face discrimination, it changes the way their expectations about the way other people are going to treat them. So it may make them more concerned about being judged or being rejected or excluded because of their race or ethnicity.
他们接触到更多的室外污染以及更多的犯罪和暴力。因此，他们总体上接触到更多的压力源。这些压力源本身会发生变化，因为它们创造了一个人们生活的环境，并改变了人们对自我、他人以及整个世界的想法和感受。因此，歧视是许多群体面临的一个压力源，种族或族裔歧视改变了人们对自我以及最重要的是对他人的想法和感受。因此，当人们面临歧视时，它会改变他们对其他人将如何对待他们的期望。因此，这可能会使他们更担心因为自己的种族或族裔而被评判、拒绝或排斥。
And those are the kinds of changes in thinking that affect people throughout the day and potentially change their relationships, their approach to other people, but also their physiological responses to those interchanges, exchanges that they have with other people. And what do you mean by physiological responses? Well, one area of research that we're currently exploring is the degree to which it changes, for example, blood pressure responses or inflammatory responses when people are engaging with other individuals. So it is the case, actually, that whether you're looking at individuals
而这些正是贯穿整天影响人们的思维变化，并可能改变他们的关系、他们对待他人的方法，以及他们对这些互动（即他们与他人的交往）的生理反应。你所说的生理反应是什么意思？嗯，我们目前正在探索的一个研究领域是，当人们与其他人交往时，它在多大程度上改变了例如血压反应或炎症反应。因此，事实上，无论你是在看个人
who are in sexual minority groups or racial or ethnic minority groups, there's a consistent effect of discrimination on smoking, for example. And for African Americans, there's increasing evidence that discrimination is related to changes in obesity over time. But not all groups are equally at risk for obesity or for smoking or for binge drinking, for example. But it is important to understand that discrimination itself has effects on the rates of smoking and how frequently people smoke. And it has effects on potentially has some effects or on changes in obesity over time. There are also environmental stressors, particularly in lower income communities.
属于性少数群体还是种族或少数族裔群体，歧视对吸烟等行为具有一致的影响。对于非裔美国人来说，越来越多的证据表明歧视与随着时间推移肥胖的变化有关。但并非所有群体面临肥胖、吸烟或暴饮暴食风险的程度都相同。然而，重要的是要理解歧视本身对吸烟率以及人们吸烟的频率有影响。它对肥胖随时间的变化也可能产生一些影响。环境压力源也存在，特别是在低收入社区。
Can you talk more about what those are and how they can impact? people's health. This is a very interesting new line of research which suggests that certain kinds of environmental threats like lead exposure may actually potentiate your reactivity, cardiovascular reactivity, to other kinds of stress. So understanding the ways in which environmental exposures make changes maybe in the expression of our genes or the regulation of our autonomic nervous system, cardiovascular system, that's an area of research that's really important. It sounds like you have a really interesting job where you're able to sort of work on both sides of the psychological spectrum in the field and the research. I really love working with the patients
你能多谈谈这些是什么以及它们如何影响人们的健康吗。这是一条非常有趣的新研究路线，表明某些种族的环境威胁，如铅暴露，实际上可能会增强你对其他类型压力的反应性，即心血管反应性。因此，了解环境暴露如何在我们的基因表达或自主神经系统、心血管系统的调节中做出改变，这是一个非常重要的研究领域。听起来你有一份非常有趣的工作，能够同时在心理学谱系的两端工作，包括实地和研究。我真的很喜欢与患者合作
and testing different hypotheses and making relationships at the time. And I also really love working with the students being able to generate new hypotheses and testing them out in the field. And in fact, I'll tell you about an exciting thing that we're doing in collaboration. St. John's University is doing in collaboration with Jamaica Hospital Medical Center. We've developed the collaborative health integration research program, which we call CHIRP. CHIRP. And our logo is actually a little bird with a lab coat. But what's really exciting about this program is that it's a real integration of research and clinical practice.
并在当时测试不同的假设以及建立关系。我也非常喜欢与学生合作，能够产生新的假设并在实地进行测试。事实上，我将告诉你一件我们在合作中正在做的激动人心的事。圣约翰大学正在与牙买加医院医疗中心合作。我们开发了合作健康整合研究项目，我们称之为CHIRP。CHIRP。我们的标志实际上是一只穿着白大褂的小鸟。但这个项目真正令人兴奋的是它是研究和临床实践的真正整合。
So we have family medicine residents participating, clinical psychology graduate students and experimental psychology graduate students, undergraduates from the psychology program, and even high school students from advanced high schools in the city, all working together to do research on health disparities. And they test their ideas in the field and in the lab. So that's been a wonderful opportunity to do that kind of multidisciplinary research that is really necessary to reduce health disparities. Well, thank you so much for coming and talking with us today. Really appreciate it.
因此，我们有家庭医学住院医师参与、临床心理学研究生和实验心理学研究生、心理学项目的本科生，甚至来自该市高级高中的高中生，大家一起合作开展关于健康差距的研究。他们在实地和实验室测试他们的想法。因此，这是一个极好的机会，可以进行这种真正减少健康差距所必需的多学科研究。好的，非常感谢你今天来和我们交谈。非常感谢。
Okay, thank you. Thanks for listening. To hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Andre Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，谢谢。感谢收听。要收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是安德烈·汉密尔顿，代表美国心理学协会的《心理学话语》。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。